it's morning time in the heart of the
German capital here at the Brandenburg
Gate bike taxis are doing good business
fair especially popular with tourists
who avail of the city tours the drivers
offer
tillu more has been operating a bike
taxi for 13 years this is a super job
for me I've always loved cycling and I
like to get moving I get paid for it I'm
never bored I get to show people the
city and they're usually really
impressed not every job is like that he
charges 45 euros for a tour of the city
do you want a ride are we too heavy no
you're not you're as light as a feather
together the driver passengers and bike
weigh about 350 kilos
it's an extra boost is required there's
a manually operated electric motor that
allows till Houma to save his breath for
all the talking he does during the tour
here you can get a good view of the
front of the right stock it's lit up
nicely in the evening to nibble or
something that the bike taxi enables
passengers to access places closed off
to conventional taxis and tour buses
like Berlin's largest park for example
the driver covers a distance of between
30 and 100 kilometers a day when you
spend the whole summer cycling you don't
get aches and pains as long as you take
enough breaks eat something a few
bananas then it's fine
[Music]
the bikes are pretty high-tech they were
designed and built in the southern
German state of Bavaria by a company
called bike cycle rickshaws originated
in Japan bike has given them a modern
twist it takes two hours to charge up
the battery for the motor considering it
can ferry three people two in the back
plus the driver and has a range of 60
kilometers it could replace a car bike
employs six people should we test the
motor engineer stefan kosher designed
the bike taxi a quick check to make sure
everything's in order it took over eight
years to develop the prototype kind of
it doesn't have a combustion engine it
has two driving forces the person
themself produces a bit of co2 but
that's allowed the electric motor
produces no co2 so it's an eco-friendly
vehicle and a bike taxi will set you
back ten thousand euros to sweeten the
deal the engineer has designed the
vehicle to accommodate adds bike gets a
small part of the cut most of the ad
revenue goes to the driver it takes
about five months to pay back the value
of the bike taxi
Stefan kosher began building bike taxis
17 years ago
he's even designed a solar powered
version bike taxis can be found in a
hundred and twenty cities around the
world including Munich Tokyo and Durban
crew chose bike taxis are also
attracting interest in the Ethiopian
capital addis ababa is finding fabrica
is a test for us
beginning in addis ababa we hope we can
establish ourselves well there our
partners are certainly coming to us for
environmental reasons they're happy to
have found a business model that can
also support eco-friendly aims some 205
taxis are already on the streets of
Berlin to Wawa has just completed his
first ride of the day
I secession well it was really great
everything was well explained I'm sure
we'll do it again sometime
for tulum ah it's time to find his next
passengers
[Music]